Speaker 1: . Donald Trump resurfaced yesterday on
Fox News's Sean Hannity program and told many of
the same corrosive lies that he's been telling
about the 2020 election since November. And why
wouldn't we expect that Trump was still telling
the same corrosive and debunked lies about the
2016 election as recently as January, if Trump
still hasn't accepted the results of the 2016
election? Why on earth would we expect him
to accept the results of the 2020 election?
Everything about this interview is hilarious.
Here is Sean Hannity introducing it, Sean Hannity
framing this as a major exclusive. But if you're
watching, you will see Trump doesn't even seem
pleased to be sitting for this interview tonight
Speaker 3: for the hour. We welcome the 44th
president of the United States, Donald Trump.
Mr. President, good to see you. Thanks for
joining us. Well, thank you very much.
Speaker 1: All right. OK, so now they
get into what we could call the substance,
although there wasn't very much substance.
And here Trump jumps right into provable
debunk a bull, easily disprovable lies
that in presidential reelections, presidents
tend to get fewer votes in their reelection
than in their first election. It's just not
true. We're going to look at the numbers,
but watch Trump use the lie to somehow,
I guess, continue making the case that
Joe Biden didn't really win many other things.
Speaker 4: Big thing is taxes,
low taxes, low taxes. You're going to have the
biggest tax increase you've ever seen, a pro-life
Second Amendment. So many different things.
Speaker 1: Now, I hate to cut in already the tax
increase. Joe Biden is looking at
would not be the biggest in history.
Trump did barely a thing on abortion. Trump
did nothing on the Second Amendment. OK,
let's go to the core of it, though,
Speaker 4: that,
look, we got 75 million votes. It's more than any
sitting president in history by far. The word was,
if we got 65 to 66, we got 63. The first time in
one. If you got 65 to 66, there was no way you
lost. We got more votes. We got 12 million more
votes than we got. And it's never happened to
another president. I don't know. I mean, usually
in a second term, a president gets less votes.
I got 12 million more. It's the biggest
that's ever happened in history from 63 to 75.
Never happened before. And all of these
things are good. These are popular things,
but more important than popular,
they're great things for this country.
They're going to rip apart your Second Amendment.
Speaker 1: Now, first of all, it is fewer votes,
not less votes, Mr. President. But let's
not start the grammar policing. I know
he only went to Wharton, but what Trump says
is not true. Trump says presidents typically
get fewer votes in their reelections. Check out
the numbers. Obama did get fewer votes. He lost
four million votes from 2008 to 2012, but George
W. Bush gained 12 million votes in his reelection.
Bill Clinton gained three million votes. Ronald
Reagan gained 11 million votes. Richard Nixon
gained 16 million votes, and Dwight D. Eisenhower
gained a million votes. So really, other than
Barack Obama, you have to go back to World War Two
for a president whose votes declined after their
first term. And it's kind of a weird example. It's
an exception to the rule. It's FDR who had four
terms and whose presidency in so many ways was the
exception to the rule. Maybe what Trump means is
Obama got fewer votes in the second term. And
we know Trump is obsessed with Barack Obama.
Maybe that's all that this is really about, but
an easily disprovable lie from Donald Trump.
Check out this suck up question from Sean
Hannity. It's not even really a question.
It's like a gushing statement of praise, the
likes of which you'd expect from North Korean
television, sort of like a Mr. President.
Can you confirm how hard you're working?
Speaker 3: So I know a lot of people that are
around you every day. This is what they're
all telling me. You are working as hard as
you did when you were in the White House,
except you play a little golf war
that you're keeping an insane schedule
seven days a week. You really don't stop.
Speaker 4: Well, we're seeing a lot of people
we're seeing a lot of good Republicans and a lot
of good Americans, in some cases great Americans.
Speaker 1: And Hannity is doing the equivalent
of Kim Jong un bold for the first time today. And
he bowled the 300. He also turned water into
wine. This apparently counts as an interview
on Fox News. Now, I told you yesterday that the
Treasury Department put out a report confirming
coordination between Donald Trump's 2016. Campaign
chairman Paul Manafort and a Russian intelligence
officer, Konstantin Kilim Nick, the topic of
Russia came up and Trump says something completely
unintelligible, but he does do the search routine
where he claims, someone came to me and they said,
sir, take a look at this.
Speaker 3: You did run and did win.
What would you do differently?
Speaker 4: When I came in, we were hit with Sony,
Russia, Russia, Russia investigations. It was a
total phony deal. That was three years of your
presidency. I've been I've been fighting off
investigations for five years. I mean, really
since that almost a day that we came down and they
were corrupt, Democrat inspired. I still have it.
They were Democrat inspired investigations.
Russia, I remember John, and I don't have too
much time, I guess, with you. But a story I think
it's interesting. I haven't told that before.
During the campaign in 2016, I'd be asked by
one of our aides, sir, do you have anything
to do with Russia? I say, no, no, that would
be it. Then a month later, somebody would say,
what do you know about Russia? I said, what,
I don't know what you're talking about, OK,
I wouldn't think of it then after three or four or
five times people would say anything about Russia,
I kept saying no. So after three or four times, I
said, what's going on with Russia? They created a
phony deal. It was paid for by Hillary Crooked.
Speaker 3: Hillary Clinton made a phony Russian
disinformation dossier. Roy Oh. And they used
it to spy on you as a candidate, wrecked your
transition team. And while you were president, it
says at the top of a FISA warrant, verified it was
unverifiable and they knew
Speaker 4: it 17 times.
Speaker 3: They knew it right from the get go.
Speaker 1: I don't know what either of them are
talking about, but they seem to be kind
of playing off of each other and winding
each other up. Here's a few more seconds from
this portion of the interview. They knew what
Speaker 3: they were warned beforehand
and they knew it certainly from
Christopher Steele and the sub source by
Speaker 4: total fraud. And you know what it did?
It hurt any possibility of dealing with Russia. We
could have we could have had a good luck. They'll
say, oh, he loves Russia. Getting along with
Russia is a good thing, not a bad thing. Getting
along with China is a good thing. The problem we
Speaker 1: have now, when Trump was asked whether
he will run again, this just like he can't
answer any question, normally he said that
from a legal standpoint, he doesn't
really want to talk about that.
Speaker 4: I say this. I am looking at it
very seriously beyond seriously from a legal
standpoint, I don't want to really talk
about it yet. It's a little too if you did
Speaker 1: run, what does that even mean from a
legal standpoint? Like part of me thinks it has
to do with Trump wanting to use donations
as a slush fund for his personal expenses?
I don't know why my mind goes to that, but
like, what could he even mean from a legal
standpoint? And then Trump was also asked about
Republican vaccine hesitancy and Trump said he
doesn't really know why Republicans are hesitant
to take the vaccine for covid. Take a look.
Speaker 4: You know, they all want me to do a
commercial because a lot of our people don't
want to take vaccine. You know, I don't know what
that is exactly. Republican. I don't know what it
is. You encourage people to go. I encourage them
to take it. I do. But they want me to make of
it. You get it? They yes, they had it and I took
it. OK, you got both because I believe so. Here's
here's the thing. They want me to do a commercial.
Speaker 1: Trump can't imagine why Republicans
wouldn't be getting the vaccine because for
a year, Trump said this wasn't serious. If
something's not serious, why would anybody need
a vaccine? That's why there's so much vaccine
hesitancy. So just a completely bizarre interview
and unclear what the point of it is. I guess Sean
Hannity wants ratings and Trump wants attention.
Like maybe it's that simple. And we don't need to
analyze the motivations more deeply, but expect
much more of this. If Donald Trump's Q and on
congressional allies get reelected in 2022,
Trump will be reinvigorated. You're going to
see this much more regularly. And it may
be what gets Donald Trump to run in 2024,
as we've talked about before. So very important
that we ensure Trump doesn't get his people.
You know, Marjorie Taylor Green and Lauren
Bobert, Madison, Cawthorn, the gym, you know,
whoever anybody that can be removed in 2022 will
make it less likely that Trump even runs in 2024.